we spent over a trillion dollars
over 20 years
we trained and equipped with modern
equipment over 300
000 afghan forces
and
afghan leaders
have to come together
we lost
thousands that lost death and injury
thousands of american personnel
they've got to fight for themselves
fight for their nation
the united states
i'll insist we continue
to keep the commitments we made
of providing close air support
making sure that their air force
functions and is operable
resupplying
their forces with food and equipment
and paying all their salaries
but they've got to want to fight
they have outnumbered the taliban
and i'm getting daily briefings
i think there's still a possibility you
have a
significant
new
secretary of defense our equivalent of
secretary of defense in afghanistan
bushmilla khan
who's a serious fighter
i think they're beginning to realize
they've got to come together politically
at the top
and but we're going to continue to keep
our commitment but i do not regret my
decision